Homeopathy, beloved by The Royal Family and
millions around the world.
But does it actually work?
Hey guys Julia here for DNews
Homeopathy.
A very.. contentious form of alternative medicine
practiced by millions all over the world.
The National Health Service in the UK spends
about 4 million pounds a year on these kind
of treatments.
And some estimates place that number as high
as 11 million pounds.
So it’s more than just a fringe movement.
In fact even the Royal Family seems to be
fans.
The Queen’s Physician, Peter Fisher, recently
called for more people to use it.
He says that it’s “Safe, popular with
patients, improves clinical outcomes without
increasing costs, and reduces the use of potentially
hazardous drugs, including antimicrobials.”
Although in the US, the National Institute
of Health says that “There is little evidence
to support homeopathy as an effective treatment
for any specific condition.”
So what is it?
Homeopathy isn’t a new idea.
It was introduced by the German Physician
Samuel Hahnemann over 200 years ago.
Homeopathy’s premise is based on a few interesting
ideas.
According to The National Center for Homeopathy,
the first idea is that “like cures like”
and that’s what homeopathy means in Greek,
same suffering.
Or that something that produces symptoms in
a healthy person, makes a sick person healthy.
So like caffeine, a molecule that keeps people
awake, might be used to treat people with
insomnia.
But only if caffeine is diluted to very small
amounts.
And that’s the second premise.
The more dilute the remedy, the more potent
it is.
And thirdly, that the illness is specific
to the person.
Homeopaths take into account a holistic view
of a person.
So how is the medicine made?
Well let’s go back to that caffeine example.
A bit of caffeine goes through the process
of 'potentization’ which involves dilution
and succussion (vigorous shaking), so all
the toxic effects of the extract or compound
are removed.
And when I say dilution, I mean a lot of dilution.
Something might be diluted 1 in a hundred
30 times in a solution of water or sugar.
Medicine doses are based on the centesimal
or C scale.
A 2C dilution requires a substance to be diluted
to one part in one hundred, and then some
of that mixture being diluted AGAIN to one
part in a hundred.
So basically you wind up with one part of
the original substance in 10,000 parts of
the solution.
And so on and so forth.
This process can be repeated.
Basically the plant or animal extract is so
diluted that there’s almost no molecules
of it left.
But according to homeopathic theory the more
diluted it is, the more “potency” it has.
Homeopaths believe that water retains the
“memory” of that extract.
The idea is that after each dilution the extract
and water, sugar, or what ever the dilution
is, goes through succussion, which activates
the “vital energy” of the extract.
Alright so that’s the process… but what
does the science say about it?
Well one study published in the journal Rheumatology
found that homeopathy helped arthritis patients
over the course of six months, when added
alongside conventional medicine.
Buuuuuuut it was because of “its unique
consultation process,".
Basically homeopathy treats the patient, not
just the symptoms.
So it was really the one on one, patient focused
appointments that helped, not the homeopathic
medicine.
Well the National Health and Medical Research
Council of Australia found “no evidence”
that homeopathy is effective.
In a report published last year, the NHMRC
looked at 57 systematic reviews of the treatment.
They found there were no health conditions
for which homeopathy was effective, that no
good large scale studies found that homeopathy
was better than placebo.
And Edzard Ernst, emeritus professor, at the
University of Exeter wrote in an opposing
letter to the Queen’s physician, that homeopathy
is “implausible” and that it “flies
in the face of science”.
So it looks like science isn’t on the side
of homeopathy.
But you know what science
DOES support?
Meditation.